Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
C'est une semaine un peu spéciale en Belgique puisque, en plus du 8 mars, la Journée internationale des droits de la femme, il y a également ce jeudi un vote à la Chambre des représentants pour dépénaliser totalement l'IVG
et pour allonger de 12 à 18 semaines le délai durant lequel une femme peut obtenir une intervention volontaire de grossesse.
Du coup, c'est l'occasion de se pencher sur un service de santé publique qui est au cœur de toutes ces questions : les centres de planning familial.
J'ai eu le plaisir d'interviewer en début de semaine Lola Clavreul et Émilie Saey, qui travaillent ensemble au sein de la Fédération des Centres Pluralistes de Planning Familial. Ensemble, on revient un peu
sur l'histoire des centres de planning familial en Belgique.
À quoi ça sert ? Qui y va ? On déconstruit les idées reçues au sujet de ces centres, on discute de l'état des choses concernant l'avortement en Belgique et on parle bien évidemment de l'éducation à la vie relationnelle, affective et sexuelle.
J'ai passé un très bon moment avec elles, donc j'espère que ça vous plaira aussi. C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Émilie Saey et Lola Clavreul.
Émilie, Lola, bonjour.
Bonjour. Bonjour.
On va parler aujourd'hui de la Fédération des Centres Pluralistes de Planning Familial, puisque, Émilie, tu es la directrice du FCPPF.
C'est correct.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter chacune pour ceux et celles qui ne vous connaissent pas ?
Nous présenter nous ou présenter la Fédération ?
En tant que personne et puis la Fédération après, oui.
Bonjour, moi, c'est Émilie Saey. Je suis directrice de la Fédération depuis bientôt quatre ans. Qui suis-je ? Une jeune femme de 30 ans, militante, féministe, engagée. Voilà.
Parfait. Lola ?
Moi, je travaille à la Fédération depuis presque deux ans. Je travaille en éducation permanente et en plaidoyer politique et je suis également féministe et très engagée.
Tu t'occupes plus spécifiquement, d'après ce que tu m'as dit, des centres en Wallonie.
Oui, exactement. On a ici 25 centres affiliés. On a des centres à Bruxelles et des centres en région wallonne. Et comme on n'a pas exactement les mêmes décrets
pour les centres de planning familial à Bruxelles et en région wallonne, on s'est partagé la défense politique.
Donc, je m'occupe de la région wallonne et Émilie s'occupe de Bruxelles.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler un petit peu ce que c'est, le FCPPF ?
Oui, la Fédération des Centres Pluralistes, c'est une association, donc une ASBL, qui a deux missions. La première, c'est de défendre les centres de planning qui sont affiliés chez nous.
On a 25 centres, 6 à Bruxelles et 19 en région wallonne.
Et sa deuxième mission, c'est un organisme d'éducation permanente, c'est-à-dire qu'on crée des outils pédagogiques à destination des animateurs et des animatrices qui vont faire des animations EVRAS,
mot barbare que je vais détailler tout de suite—
Ouais.
...qui vont faire des animations EVRAS dans les écoles. Les EVRAS, c'est quoi ? C'est l'éducation à la vie relationnelle, affective et sexuelle.
Est-ce que c'est récent, ça ? Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui existait déjà, le concept de EVRAS ? Parce que moi, j'étais à l'école il y a 15 ans, je me souviens pas qu'on employait ce mot-là.
En effet.
Ouais, c'est récent ?
On l'appelait pas EVRAS. En fait, les animations à la sexualité, de manière plus globale, elles ont commencé dans les années 70.
Ce sont les centres de planning qui sont entrés dans les écoles et qui ont commencé à faire des animations. C'étaient des animations qui étaient plutôt basées sur la peur.
On va faire attention aux IST, on va utiliser des moyens de contraception, on va prévenir des grossesses non désirées. Avec le temps, on a élargi l'éducation à la sexualité de manière plus globale, parce qu'il n'y a pas que ça.
La santé, elle est globale. Donc, on a appelé ça éducation à la vie relationnelle, affective et sexuelle, car on n'aborde pas que les IST, que la contraception, les IVG, etc.
C'est bien plus large, on aborde les émotions, le respect, l'intimité, le consentement, les stéréotypes de genre, etc.
On va revenir sur la notion de EVRAS, de éducation vie relationnelle, affective et sexuelle un peu plus tard. Mais avant ça, tu disais Fédération de centres de planning familial.
Il y a un mot dans ce FCPPF qui est intéressant, c'est le P : pluralisme. D'où est-ce que ça vient ? Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Pourquoi pluralisme ?
Déjà, ce qu'il faut peut-être expliquer, c'est qu'en Belgique, en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, il y a quatre fédérations de centres de planning familial.
Oui.
On a un pilier anciennement chrétien, la FCPC, la Fédération des Centres de Planning Familial des Femmes Prévoyantes Socialistes, la Fédération laïque et puis nous, la Fédération pluraliste.
On est quatre fédérations à s'occuper des 107 centres qui existent.
Ok, donc on a vraiment ce côté Belgique polarisée, socialiste, catholique, laïque, libérale. Et puis ce quatrième, pluraliste, et ça, ça m'intéresse très fort.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? D'où ça vient ? Pourquoi ?
Non, déjà, juste un petit mot sur la FCPC anciennement chrétienne. C'est comme le CDH, elle a changé son nom.
On ne se dit plus du pilier chrétien, mais à la base, c'étaient des centres plutôt de ce pilier chrétien et du coup, qui travaillaient beaucoup sur les consultations de conseils conjugaux, essayer de refaire couple ensemble.
Ça n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui. Et ce qui a vachement polarisé les fédérations de centres de planning, ça a été notamment, par exemple, l'IVG, où le pilier chrétien était moins favorable.
Ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui non plus. Donc pourquoi est-ce qu'il reste quatre fédérations ? Parce que ça reste des questions éthiques et ce n'est pas toujours facile, ça reste compliqué.
Et en fait, le pluralisme, ça vient du fait que plusieurs mondes se sont croisés, donc se sont croisés autour du pluralisme.
Le premier centre pluraliste, en fait, c'est le centre de Uccle
et il a été fondé par des personnes qui venaient du mouvement laïque, par des personnes qui venaient de la Ligue des familles qui étaient pluralistes
et par des personnes qui venaient du monde chrétien et qui se sont dit : « On travaille tous dans nos sphères et on va proposer des centres où la personne qui vient
à l'accueil pourra décider si elle veut être suivie par quelqu'un qui sera laïque plutôt ou qui sera issu du monde chrétien, et cetera.
Donc plutôt que de faire un centre de planning familial qui est de nature catholique ou un centre qui est de nature laïque, on va faire un seul et puis les personnes qui viennent peuvent choisir—
Voilà.
...je veux consulter une personne plutôt catholique, une personne plutôt laïque.
C'était l'essence—
Et être conseillée sur base de ça.
Tout à fait. C'était l'essence des centres pluralistes et le fait de pouvoir dialoguer en fait autour des différences.
C'est-à-dire que les deux ou trois, enfin en fait aujourd'hui, toutes les confessions, les communautés de croyance existent et que, au lieu de chacun être dans son coin, qu'on puisse se rassembler et parler de ces différences
et s'entendre ensemble autour de ces différences.
Et ça fonctionne bien ?
Bah ça a fonctionné vu que du premier centre pluraliste, il y en a eu d'autres. Et puis aujourd'hui, il y en a vingt-cinq.
Donc oui, ça fonctionne.
Non, je voulais juste rajouter une chose, c'est que, au-delà de la volonté de faire coexister des mondes qui
étaient peut-être un peu séparés, il y a eu vraiment la volonté de les faire coexister dans les conseils d'administration aussi.
C'était pas juste au niveau des professionnels qui venaient donner des consultations dans les centres, c'était dans l'essence même des structures, cette volonté-là.
Concrètement, ça veut dire que entre les différents centres que vous gérez, les vingt-cinq centres que vous gérez dans la, enfin...
Non. On ne les gère pas, on les représente et on les soutient.
OK.
Voilà.
Parfait.
Ce sont des centres indépendants qui peuvent s'affilier là ou là et qui ont décidé d'être affiliés à la Fédération pluraliste.
D'accord. Donc entre les vingt-cinq centres que vous supervisez et que vous soutenez,
est-ce que déjà entre ces vingt-cinq centres, on observe des différences en termes philosophiques ou bien est-ce que la pluralité se fait au sein de chacun de ces centres ?
Il y a plusieurs façons d'aborder la question, mais quand une personne se rend dans un centre de planning pour quelle que soit la raison, je crois que le bé— enfin nous, on parle de bénéficiaire.
Donc le bénéficiaire se fiche royalement de savoir s'il est dans un centre qui appartient à la Fédération laïque, à la Fédération pluraliste.
OK.
Je sais pas, sa préoccupation—
Pourquoi est-ce que ça existe si tout le monde s'en fout ?
C'est historique.
OK.
Principalement, c'est historique. Peut-être qu'un jour, on arrivera à avoir une seule fédération, mais pour l'instant, c'est comme ça.
Mais enfin vraiment, en tout cas, y a pas de différence d'accueil entre un centre pluraliste, un centre laïque, un centre des FCPC ou un centre socialiste, aucune.
Donc c'est vraiment, c'est intéressant parce qu'on aurait tendance à se dire : bah le centre catholique va pas trop avoir envie de parler d'IVG.
Est-ce que c'est plus avéré, ça, aujourd'hui ?
Non, c'est plus du tout vrai. Et en fait, ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est que y a des centres, donc, enfin on va pas les appeler centres catholiques, mais les centres qui sont affiliés à la FCPC, qui aimeraient bien pouvoir pratiquer l'IVG.
Mais en fait, comme il y a un moratoire de la part de l'INAMI, on n'arrive plus à ouvrir des centres IVG aujourd'hui.
On n'arrive pas à en ouvrir davantage que ce qui existe.
OK. Donc ça, ça s'applique à tous les centres.
Oui.
Il y a un moratoire.
Pourquoi ?
On peut demander ça à l'INAMI. Pourquoi ?
C'est... Personne ne sait ?
Non, vraiment, je ne sais pas pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, les centres, y a pas des nouveaux centres qui peuvent s'ouvrir alors qu'il y a des demandes.
Il y a des demandes. On est en manque de—
Nous, on a des centres de planning qui font la demande, mais la demande n'est pas, enfin, c'est lettre morte. Et donc aujourd'hui, l'INAMI n'a pas l'intention d'ouvrir des nouveaux centres IVG.
Et vous leur avez posé la question de savoir pourquoi ?
Non. Aujourd'hui, on n'a pas posé, nous, la question à l'INAMI de savoir pourquoi.
Mais par contre, une autre différence, je dirais, historique entre les fédérations et du coup les centres de planning, c'est que la majorité des centres IVG sont des centres laïques.
Ça, c'est une vraie différence. Parce que ce sont, c'est quand même le—
C'est historique, ça ?
...les laïques qui ont beaucoup porté, oui, oui, le,
enfin voilà, l'IVG historiquement.
Et du coup, la grande majorité des centres IVG sont affiliés à la Fédération laïque,
même s'il y en a aussi pas mal qui sont affiliés chez les FPS, donc
Femmes, enfin la Fédération des femmes prévoyantes socialistes et que là, c'est une autre dynamique parce qu'en fait, c'est une mutualité, c'est Solidaris, qui offre des services centres de planning à ses membres.
OK. Donc beaucoup de niveaux de pouvoir différents, de mutualités, les piliers, voilà, donc beaucoup de choses qui s'imbriquent.
Encore le vieux monde, ouais.
Ouais, ouais, c'est ça. OK. Alors donc on parle maintenant de la Fédération, on parle de pluralisme et tout ça, mais on a un petit peu sauté une étape.
Un centre de planning familial en soi, qu'est-ce que c'est ? Pourquoi on y va ? Quels services sont offerts ? Comment ça marche ?
Un centre de planning familial. Alors, ben déjà, n'importe qui peut y aller. Tout le monde est le bienvenu. Pourquoi on y va ?
Donc y a plusieurs possibilités. On peut aller y trouver juste un accueil pour poser une question, pour quelque chose, enfin je parle, un événement de la vie, voilà.
On peut aller chercher, demander une consultation en psy, auprès d'un psychologue, auprès d'un médecin. On peut demander des consultations juridiques et des consultations sociales, donc avec un ou une assistante sociale.
Les centres de planning, qu'est-ce qu'ils font aussi ? Bah, ils sont pas refermés sur eux-mêmes. Donc, ils vont aller aussi donner des animations EVRAS.
Donc, on a déjà parlé des EVRAS tout à l'heure, mais donc dans les écoles, mais aussi hors des écoles, d'avoir un stand de sensibilisation sur telle ou telle thématique, le harcèlement, par exemple.
D'accord. OK, mais donc ça, c'est beaucoup de, c'est des catégories très vagues. Donc, il y a des gens qui viennent chercher du soutien psychologique, social, des conseils.
Mais dans le concret, typiquement, ce qu'on voit arriver là-bas, c'est quoi ? Des jeunes— on va revenir là-dessus, mais j'imagine que ce sont plutôt des femmes qui viennent dans les centres de planning familial, c'est juste ?
Oui, oui, c'est juste.
Et donc typiquement, on voit quoi ? Ce sont des jeunes femmes en détresse ou bien des jeunes femmes plutôt à l'aise ou qu'est-ce que ?
Non, je pense que ça, c'est un peu un cliché qu'on a sur les centres. On a l'impression que c'est surtout des adolescentes qui vont y aller pour demander un avortement, par exemple.
C'est assez fort, un gros cliché. Qui est-ce qui fréquente les centres ? Oui, ça, c'est sûr qu'il y a davantage de femmes.
Après, ça va vraiment dépendre d'un centre à l'autre. Ça va dépendre de où est situé le centre. Est-ce qu'il est en plein cœur d'une grande ville ?
Est-ce qu'il est à la campagne ? Est-ce qu'il est à proximité d'une école ? Ou est-ce qu'il va faire aussi des animations, des sensibilisations ?
Et donc quel genre de public il va ramener à l'intérieur du centre. Ça dépend, on observe par exemple qu'il y a beaucoup de centres qui
ont énormément de demandes sur les consultations psychologiques, mais parce que dans certaines régions, il y a vraiment un manque de...
'fin, en fait, il y a des structures de santé mentale qui sont déjà surchargées et qui vont du coup envoyer des patients.
'fin, allez, peut-être pas les envoyer, mais en tout cas, y a une masse de patients qui va être redirigée vers le centre de planning.
Donc en fait, c'est difficile de faire un portrait type de la personne qui pousse la porte du centre.
Mh. OK.
Non, je voulais juste rajouter qu'il y a aussi des consultations de sexologie, de médiation familiale et de conseils conjugaux et familial.
D'accord, OK. Beh justement—
Et donc globalement, les gens qui s'adressent à un centre de planning,
c'est des gens qui viennent pour une problématique relative à la vie relationnelle, affective et sexuelle, que ce soit une séparation, des problèmes dans un couple, des problèmes avec son enfant,
au niveau médical, besoin d'une contraception, contraception qui n'est pas adaptée, que ce soit, voilà, petite gynécologie, et cetera.
Ça reste de manière globale les problématiques de la vie relationnelle, affective et sexuelle.
On touchait à ça il y a un instant, mais donc on disait le profil des gens qui viennent, plutôt des femmes. Comment ça se fait ?
Comment ça se fait ? Bah parce que c'est, on sait que les femmes sont les principales consommatrices de soins de santé.
En tout cas, c'est elles qui vont davantage se... 'fin, déjà, elles ont un parcours de santé, les femmes, qui est particulièrement chargé puisqu'en fait, y a beaucoup d'injonctions qui pèsent sur la santé des femmes.
Donc, on va les amener à aller en consultation très jeune, dès qu'elles ont leurs premières règles ou alors dès qu'elles commencent à avoir des rapports sexuels.
Et puis en fait, elles ont un parcours médical qui court après jusqu'à la ménopause avec des consultations très régulières.
C'est quelque chose qui n'existe pas chez les hommes.
D'accord.
Et en plus, elles vont aussi, c'est les femmes qui vont inciter les enfants et les hommes à aller en consultation, donc ils vont les accompagner, et cetera.
C'est pour ça qu'elles sont très présentes.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose de plutôt construit ? Est-ce que c'est quelque chose de plutôt...
C'est très construit. 'fin, c'est très codifié. Je veux dire, quand on décide, alors qu'il n'y a pas de raison médicale valable, d'amener une fille chez le gynéco parce qu'elle a ses règles.
Aucun intérêt.
D'accord, OK.
'fin, je veux dire, non, ça, 'fin voilà. Non, non, c'est totalement construit, oui. Et c'est une grosse pression qui pèse sur la santé des femmes.
C'est quelque chose que justement, dans ces centres de planning familial, on essaye de déconstruire ou bien on les accueille tels quels, on leur dit : « Vous êtes les bienvenus, continuez à venir ».
Oui, de toute façon, évidemment qu'elles sont les bienvenues et qu'elles sont encouragées à venir pour poser toutes les questions qu'elles ont à poser.
Après, est-ce qu'on leur dit de venir moins souvent ? Je pense typiquement,
en ce qui concerne les consultations de gynécologie, il y avait tout un moment où on incitait les femmes à venir très régulièrement, à venir tous les ans, faire un frottis, et cetera.
Maintenant, on sait que ce n'est pas forcément utile, qu'on peut venir seulement tous les trois ans. 'fin, je pense que ça, c'est des messages qui passent par les centres, mais ça passe aussi...
Émilie.
Oui, oui, je voulais rajouter quelque chose sur les publics. En fait, le centre de planning, ce qu'il y a de merveilleux dans un centre de planning, c'est que c'est un endroit qui est très accessible aussi financièrement.
C'est-à-dire qu'aller voir un ou une gynéco dans le privé, ça coûte extrêmement cher.
Mh.
Et donc c'est un lieu où c'est très accessible, même un psy, même
un juriste ou une juriste. Voilà, ce sont des consultations qui coûtent cher et donc les centres de planning permettent d'avoir des consultations à faible prix et donc très accessibles pour en fait-
Pour donner une idée, les différences de prix entre le privé et dans un centre de planning familial, ça ressemble à quoi ?
Ben moi, ce que je peux dire, c'est que, par exemple, une consultation en région wallonne, c'est autour de vingt euros.
D'accord, ouais, OK.
Voilà. Une consul-- je parle des consultations psychologiques, juridiques, sociales. Après, les médecins, ben les tarifs sont indexés sur le-
Alors que ouais, dans le privé, un psychiatre, c'est plutôt quatre-vingts euros, un psychologue, soixante.
Oui, ça va tourner plutôt-
C'est ça, ouais.
...plutôt autour de cinquante ou soixante euros. Et il y a toujours une possibilité pour les personnes qui n'auraient pas les moyens financiers suffisants.
Il y a toujours une possibilité d'adapter les tarifs aussi pour ce genre de public.
Donc tu parles de ça parce que tu voulais exprimer que les publics qui vont dans les centres de planning familial sont donc, j'imagine, plus fragilisés, moins riches, non ?
Entre autres, pas que, mais entre autres.
OK.
Il y a cette accessibilité à ces publics-là, oui, tout à fait.
C'est ça, d'accord.
Avec parfois aussi moins de délais d'attente que dans le privé.
Ouais, ouais, clairement, ouais.
Ça, c'est super important.
Ça, on peut facilement l'imaginer. Et du coup, une autre question que j'avais. Donc dans le nom Centre de Planning Familial, il y a la notion de famille.
L'a priori qu'on a sur les centres de planning familial, c'est donc le cliché que tu évoquais tout à l'heure, jeune fille fragilisée qui va chercher son IVG, ou bien plutôt, voilà, des conseils de sexualité.
Voilà, les événements qu'on peut avoir par rapport à ça, des conseils qu'on peut demander par rapport à ça. On n'a pas tellement parlé jusqu'à présent de la notion de : « Bah, on va se marier, on va créer une famille », et cetera.
Le truc, le schéma très classique. Est-ce que le nom Centre de Planning Familial est pertinent ? Est-ce qu'il est à côté de la réalité ?
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Je pense que c'est un nom historique, en fait. Donc peut-être qu'il sera amené à changer. Je sais qu'en Suisse, par exemple, on parle de centres de santé sexuelle, justement.
On ne parle plus de planning familial. Donc ce nom est historique. Les centres sont identifiés comme ça. Effectivement, ce que tu dis est très juste.
Quand on parle, 'fin moi, je sais que quand je parle de ce que je fais, à la Fédération, alors que je ne suis même pas dans un centre, on me dit : « Ah oui, oui, tu fais des avortements ».
Bon, pas exactement, mais c'est vrai qu'on associe très, très vite centre de planning à avortement, alors qu'en fait, comme on l'a dit, c'est beaucoup plus large que ça.
Voilà. Après, oui, je pense que ça sera amené à changer, mais c'est toujours difficile de faire une transition quand on, voilà, pour garder des centres qui soient bien identifiés.
OK, donc c'est historique principalement. Une autre question que j'avais du coup : les centres de planning familial, c'est financé comment ?
C'est la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, justement ?
Alors non, ce n'est pas la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles qui finance les centres de planning, ce sont les régions.
OK.
Donc la région bruxelloise et la région wallonne. C'est pour ça, comme Lola disait, on a des décrets différents à Bruxelles et en région wallonne qui mettent un cadre aux centres de planning.
Alors, à ce financement structurel des régions s'ajoutent d'autres mannes de financement qui sont les APE. Vous avez peut-être entendu ça en région wallonne.
Du coup, à Bruxelles, des ACS, il y a des Marie-Belle. 'fin voilà, il y a d'autres sortes de financements.
Alors APE, ACS ?
Alors c'est Agent Contractuel Subventionné, ça, c'est certain. Et alors
Aide pour l'emploi, ouais.
Aide pour l'emploi, OK.
Aide pour l'emploi.
D'accord.
Mais donc voilà, il y a le gros du financement qui est en tout cas donné par les régions. Ça, c'est la base.
Et c'est eux qui mettent aussi le cadre stricto sensu des centres de planning, c'est-à-dire où il faut minimum un médecin, un juriste, AS, assistant social et psy.
Et alors à Bruxelles et en Région wallonne, il y a des différences, c'est-à-dire qu'on avait des médiateurs
familiaux qui étaient facultatifs dans les deux régions à la base et la Région wallonne a décidé de les enlever, les médiateurs familiaux et les médiatrices.
Donc il n'y en a plus, par exemple. Le décret a évolué et on a dit : « Ça, on arrête parce qu'on peut trouver de la médiation familiale ailleurs ».
Alors bon, là, on pose la question, c'est un peu spécial de faire jouer la concurrence entre des consultations parce que des médecins, on peut, des gynécos, on peut en trouver ailleurs aussi.
Enfin, donc voilà, ça, c'était un peu spécial au moment du changement de décret et on aimerait toujours que les médiateurs familiaux reviennent en Région wallonne.
Sur le terrain, dans les centres de planning familial, quelles sont les difficultés qu'on rencontre ? Quelles sont les frustrations que peuvent rencontrer les gens ?
Ben moi, je vais parler pour la Région wallonne,
ils aimeraient bien être mieux financés, ça, c'est sûr. Mais vraiment, enfin, le problème le plus important, c'est cette enveloppe fermée, ce qui limite considérablement leur marge d'action.
D'autant plus qu'en fait cette enveloppe qui est quand même, elle est indexée hein, elle est majorée, indexée tous les ans, mais ça ne suffit pas à, comment...
'fin par rapport à l'augmentation des salaires et par rapport à l'ancienneté des travailleurs et des travailleuses, ben en fait, cette majoration et cette indexation ne suffisent pas.
Voilà, donc ça, c'est le problème majeur. Et on se retrouve un peu, 'fin, je parle pour les centres, mais les centres se retrouvent un peu pris au piège parce qu'on leur demande d'avoir,
de fournir une certaine qualité de service, mais en même temps d'avoir des travailleurs qui ne coûtent pas cher.
OK. Donc une première difficulté qui est le financement et particulièrement en Région wallonne. En Région bruxelloise, ça va mieux du coup, le financement ?
Oui, en Région bruxelloise, il y a vraiment l'avantage que les travailleurs soient payés à leur juste barème ancienneté.
Donc ça, c'est sûr qu'au niveau du financement des salaires, ils sont bien mieux lotis qu'en Région wallonne.
Après, dans les deux régions, il y a vraiment un gros problème avec la coordination parce qu'un centre de planning, ça reste une ASBL avec toutes les obligations qui sont faites aux ASBL, c'est-à-dire comptables, législatives.
Aujourd'hui, il y a une réforme, 'fin la réforme du Code des sociétés et des associations avec toutes les nouveautés que ça implique.
Il y a le registre UBO, il y a le GDPR, 'fin RGPD, là, etc. Et donc en fait, plus coordonner une équipe, plus paiement des salaires.
Et en fait, il n'y a aucun financement aujourd'hui pour ce poste de coordination. Aujourd'hui, quelqu'un qui est engagé, qui va faire des consultations psy, juridiques, médicales ou sociales,
en fait, se retrouve à, quelqu'un dire : « Il faut que quelqu'un fasse la coordination », qui est un peu un chat dans un sac.
C'est-à-dire que c'est pas un chouette rôle. Ça, c'est pas mieux. Un chat dans un sac. Non, mais c'est un rôle difficile et qui n'est pas valorisé et qui n'est pas financé.
Donc voilà, c'est quand même compliqué la coordination. Donc nous, on milite aujourd'hui pour que ce poste soit officialisé.
Encore autre chose à rajouter, Lola ?
Oui, en fait, j'étais en train de penser, ben je pense qu'on va en parler après des animations EVRAS.
Oui, ben j'allais y venir, ouais.
Bon, mais alors, ben je, voilà, je ne suis pas l'intervieweuse de la précédente. Pardon. Non, ce que je voulais dire, c'est que donc les centres sont censés donner des animations EVRAS dans les écoles.
Et il y a une-- bon, on est quand même ravis parce qu'on voit que l'EVRAS devient un enjeu politique fort et qu'on est dans un contexte politique assez favorable à ça.
Mais là aussi, on est, 'fin, on manque de moyens humains et financiers pour pouvoir couvrir vraiment tout le territoire.
Et ça, ben je ne sais pas si c'est une difficulté ou si c'est un challenge, mais en tout cas, c'est une préoccupation des centres et de nous.
Est-ce qu'on a fait le tour sur les difficultés ? Est-ce qu'on peut passer à la suite ?
Alors, on a un gros souci en Région wallonne avec la pilule du lendemain. C'est-à-dire que c'est
une pilule qui aujourd'hui n'est plus distribuée de manière officielle dans les centres de planning parce que la pilule du lendemain ne peut être délivrée que par un médecin ou un pharmacien ou une médecin ou une pharmacienne.
Mais il y a des médecins dans les centres de planning familial ?
Tout à fait, mais pas tout le temps.
OK.
Et donc aujourd'hui, quand on vient avec une demande de pilule du lendemain à l'accueil, ça ne peut pas attendre parce que la pilule du lendemain, elle doit être prise le plus rapidement possible.
Et donc en 2014, si je ne m'abuse, la Région wallonne a décidé de ne plus financer, en tout cas, les pilules du lendemain.
Et ce n'est plus, en fait, ils ne peuvent plus la délivrer, les centres de planning, ce qui est un énorme problème.
Et en fait, ils continuent de la délivrer, en tout cas chez nous, dans les centres pluralistes, on encourage les centres à ne pas suivre la loi, à distribuer cette pilule.
Parce que en fait, quand on va à la pharmacie en tant que femme, quand on va dans une pharmacie et qu'on demande une pilule du lendemain, on nous demande simplement quand a eu lieu le rapport à risque.
Et du coup, le prix de la pilule du lendemain varie entre 10 et 35 euros selon la pilule. Il y en a deux essentiellement. Alors que dans un centre de planning, on va avoir un réel accompagnement et les pilules sont gratuites.
Et du coup, nous, on encourage vraiment les centres de planning à continuer de distribuer cette pilule, à passer outre la loi qui est mal faite.
Parfois, la loi est mal faite et ne s'applique pas bien sur le terrain, donc tant pis.
Et à Bruxelles, en fait, c'est différent parce que la ministre soutenait, en tout cas l'ancienne ministre, je suis sûre que la nouvelle ministre le soutient toujours.
En tout cas, ça n'a pas, il n'y a pas eu d'actualité par rapport à la pilule du lendemain depuis, mais soutient encore ces moyens de contraception d'urgence aujourd'hui à Bruxelles.
Et donc, mais qu'est-ce qui fait alors qu'en Région wallonne, ce n'est pas le cas ? On a une ministre qui ne soutient pas la pilule du lendemain ?
On a une ministre qui...
On avait une ministre qui avait dit qu'elle le soutenait, puis le lendemain a dit finalement non parce que son parti avait changé d'avis. Donc c'était-
Parti qui était donc le CDH, du coup.
CDH, ouais. CDH.
'Fin, c'est une question un peu touchy, mais est-ce qu'on ne retombe pas à ce moment-là sur les vieux clichés, sur le CDH et sur le
Bah il y a des moments, c'est pas des clichés.
Ouais.
Donc oui, c'est la réalité.
Concrètement, ça ressemble à quoi cette réalité-là ? Est-ce qu'on a régulièrement de la part de ce pilier-là, de la part du CDH, des choses assez conservatives en ce qui concerne la santé sexuelle et reproductive ?
Oui, clairement. Clairement.
OK.
Un exemple, IVG, par exemple, où le CDH, voilà,
n'est pas favorable à certaines choses que l'on soutient. Par rapport à la pilule du lendemain, c'était le CDH qui était au gouvernement, oui, en tout cas qui était en charge des centres de planning la législation précédente
et qui n'a pas soutenu spécialement les centres dans cette délivrance de contraception d'urgence.
Et d'ailleurs, enfin, il y a trois ans, Maggie De Block a carrément dit aux infos que la pilule du lendemain était une bombe hormonale, ce qui est loin d'être le cas.
Mais c'est juste, ça fait peur et du coup, c'est un médicament, ça fait peur. Et tout ça participe à une forme de culpabilisation des femmes en fait aujourd'hui.
Parce qu'on se dit : « Oh, j'ai eu un rapport à risque, flûte, je vais prendre une pilule du lendemain ». Ça devient un drame.
Ça ne devrait pas être un drame.
Du coup, c'est pas que le CDH, c'est... On observe ce genre de mouvement un peu partout,
C'est pas que le CDH.
...surtout dans les anciennes générations, du coup.
C'est pas que le CDH, mais un autre exemple,
c'est par rapport à l'EVRAS. Il y avait une conférence interministérielle entre plusieurs parties lors de la législature précédente et le CDH bloquait en fait les avancées par rapport à la généralisation de l'EVRAS.
Donc voilà, ça... C'est pas qu'eux, mais il y a eux aussi. Voilà.
Oui oui oui, c'est souvent eux, oui.
Oui, ce que je voulais dire, la différence, donc Émilie a dit la différence entre le fait d'aller prendre une pilule du lendemain dans un planning et aller chez le pharmacien, c'était l'accompagnement.
C'est très vrai. Chez un pharmacien, on n'est absolument pas accompagné. On va venir donner une prescription et payer et recevoir un médicament.
Ce que je voulais dire aussi, c'est qu'en fait, ce n'est pas forcément une démarche facile d'aller chercher une pilule du lendemain
chez un pharmacien, parce que suivant où on habite, ben si on habite dans un petit village et qu'on n'a pas envie d'être reconnu,
ça peut être une démarche pas du tout évidente,
alors que dans un centre, en fait, on a une garantie de confidentialité.
Ça, c'est très important. Et je crois qu'il y a encore plein de gens qui vont... Enfin, voilà, on est en plein dedans, mais l'IVG, c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas encore totalement acquis par tout le monde.
Enfin, voilà, le fait que c'est un droit des femmes d'avoir accès à l'IVG. Je crois que le droit de prendre une pilule du lendemain, ça peut être encore assez mal jugé.
Donc c'est pour ça que c'est difficile d'aller le prendre dans une officine de pharmacie. C'est plus compliqué qu'en centre.
Oui, d'où le besoin de pouvoir la trouver dans les centres de planning familial.
Oui, tout à fait. Et puis en fait, de faire tomber certains mythes sur ce que c'est qu'une pilule du lendemain.
Oui, tout à fait. Donc quand on entend il y a trois ans que Maggie De Block exprime
publiquement dans des journaux que la pilule du lendemain est une bombe hormonale, nous, on a vraiment un souci avec ça parce que ce n'est pas une bombe hormonale, c'est un mythe.
Les premières pilules du lendemain étaient certes chargées en hormones, elles le sont beaucoup moins aujourd'hui. On est à la quatrième génération de pilules.
Et du coup, en fait, ce discours alimente la peur et la culpabilité de prendre une pilule du lendemain.
On ne se sent pas bien si on prend une pilule du lendemain, on se dit : « Ouh là, qu'est-ce que je fais ? Je viens d'avaler cinq cents pilules en une fois, flûte ».
Alors que non, ce n'est pas vrai. Aujourd'hui, une pilule du lendemain, ça représente treize pilules. Qu'est-ce qui vaut mieux du coup ?
Prendre une plaquette de pilules... Non, mais je vais plus loin, mais aujourd'hui, prendre une plaquette de pilules tous les mois ou une fois une pilule du lendemain parce qu'il y a eu un échec.
Enfin, voilà, ça remet aussi en question la, pas la légitimité, mais la confiance qu'on a par rapport à cette pilule qui aujourd'hui devrait être augmentée.
Et aujourd'hui, on a peur encore de la pilule du lendemain en tant que jeune femme.
On perd en confiance dans cette pilule et du coup, on augmente en culpabilité chez les femmes qui la prennent.
Bah si notre ministre de la Santé nous dit que c'est une bombe hormonale, ça craint.
Et pourquoi est-ce qu'elle fait ça, du coup ? Enfin, qu'est-ce qui peut l'amener à faire ce genre de communication ?
Mais honnêtement, je ne sais pas, parce qu'elle-même est médecin. Donc soit elle n'est pas à jour. C'est possible qu'elle ne soit pas à jour du fait qu'il y ait des nouvelles pilules, en fait.
T'as l'air de dire que oui, c'était plutôt daté comme analyse.
Ouais. Mais donc, c'est des mythes et il y a des fausses croyances qui continuent de, voilà, de suivre cette pilule du lendemain et qui sont vraiment dommage.
Lola, tu voulais rajouter quelque chose ?
Je sens que Maggie De Block ne va pas m'aimer, mais en fait, il y a des prises de position qui sont idéologiques. Et donc, à partir du moment où on considère que le...
Enfin non, c'est très dur ce que je vais dire. C'est pas dirigé contre Maggie De Block, mais à partir du moment où on refuse...
Comment je pourrais dire ça ? On n'autorise pas les femmes à être pleinement maîtresses de leur corps et de leur santé et de leur vie.
Voilà, effectivement, ça peut prêter à toutes sortes de propos et ce genre de propos sur la pilule du lendemain, ça en fait partie.
Est-ce que t'es en train de dire que Maggie De Block et l'Open VLD ne sont pas assez féministes et sont même...
Oh, mais je ne veux pas viser spécialement Maggie De Block ou certains partis. Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'il y a des prises de position qui, ben, typiquement ce genre de sorties,
qui s'appuient sur une certaine vision de la liberté des femmes à être maîtresses de leur corps, à être maîtresses de leur santé, à être responsables de leurs choix, de leur vie sexuelle, etc., etc.
Oui, c'est beaucoup diplomatique comme—
Je suis la diplomate de cette fédé, que ce soit bien clair.
Ok, c'est parfait. On peut revenir sur ce que vous appeliez l'EVRAS, donc l'éducation à la vie relationnelle, affective et sexuelle.
Donc la FCPF est agréée en tant qu'organisme d'éducation permanente. Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? À quoi ça ressemble concrètement, l'EVRAS aujourd'hui dans les écoles en Belgique ?
Dans l'éducation permanente, il y a plusieurs axes. Nous, on est dans un axe où on doit produire des outils pédagogiques.
Donc on doit produire sept outils pédagogiques par an dans le champ de l'EVRAS, donc de l'éducation à la vie relationnelle, affective et sexuelle.
Concrètement, ça veut dire qu'on va produire principalement des jeux, en fait, 'fin des outils pédagogiques qui revêtent plusieurs formes.
Donc ça peut être, oui, des jeux, des jeux de cartes, des jeux de plateaux, ça peut être des brochures, ça peut être...
Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? Des planches anatomiques, 'fin voilà, plein de formes différentes.
Une amie m'a envoyé une photo d'un genre Trivial Pursuit sur l'EVRAS, c'est juste ?
Ouais, tout à fait. Cette année, on a sorti un Trivial Pursuit.
Donc c'est vous qui le produisez, du coup, de A à Z ?
Tout à fait, de A à Z, ouais, on fait tout. On réfléchit, on le design, on le met en forme avec l'aide, parfois, de partenaires extérieurs.
Et donc ces outils sont à destination des professionnels, mais in fine, quand on parle de jeux, de Trivial Pursuit, de jeux de cartes et tout ça, c'est plutôt pour les jeunes.
Alors en fait, nous, notre public cible, c'est plutôt les adultes, hein. On ne travaille pas directement avec les jeunes, donc ça va être les adultes, donc les professionnels en font partie.
L'idée, c'est... 'fin, allez, après, ça, je crois que c'est assez particulier à la Fédé, mais on essaye de faire aussi réfléchir les professionnels sur leur représentation des choses, sur leur— on essaye de travailler beaucoup sur l'esprit critique.
Donc on ne va pas apporter, dans nos outils, en fait, on ne va pas apporter des réponses. On ne va pas faire du travail juste d'information, mais on va essayer de remettre les choses en question, d'aborder...
Par exemple, on a fait, 'fin, je donne un exemple parce que ce sera plus clair, mais on a fait un outil l'année dernière sur la question de la pornographie.
Bon, 'fin, c'est un sujet éminemment polémique. 'fin, voilà, on a un peu tout,
tout et son contraire. On a des gens qui sont complètement pour, pour qui la pornographie, c'est le diable incarné, et puis d'autres qui vont être beaucoup plus
ouverts, peut-être trop même parfois.
Et donc nous, ce qu'on essaye de faire, c'est d'arriver avec plusieurs angles de vue. Donc on a travaillé avec une approche historique, on a travaillé
sur, bah, qu'est-ce que c'est l'industrie de la pornographie, on a travaillé sur les idées reçues qu'on pouvait avoir, qu'est-ce qu'on trouve en littérature, etc., etc.
Et donc on essaye d'aborder, de montrer que les choses ont plusieurs facettes et qu'il n'y a pas de réponse toute faite, mais qu'on peut s'exercer à réfléchir et à débattre ensemble sur ces sujets.
L'EVRAS, aujourd'hui, dans les écoles, concrètement, ça ressemble à quoi ? Est-ce que ça a évolué par rapport à il y a 15 ans, il y a 10 ans ? Est-ce que...
Oui, ça a sans doute évolué. Alors moi, j'étais pas là il y a 10 ans ou 15 ans. Ce que je sais, c'est qu'on a un protocole d'accord depuis 2013 qui visait à donner un cadre à l'EVRAS.
En fait, l'EVRAS fait partie des missions obligatoires de l'école. Ça, c'est important de le dire parce que je pense que c'est pas assez su.
Le problème, c'est que ce protocole d'accord ne dit rien sur la forme que va prendre l'EVRAS dans l'école et il ne dit rien sur le fond non plus.
Donc, en fait, ce qu'on a aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on a une disparité immense
entre des écoles où il va y avoir des projets de dingue qui vont être mis en place sur plusieurs années avec parfois une cellule EVRAS qui va être intégrée complètement à l'école.
Et puis des écoles où il y aura une espèce d'affiche dans le couloir du troisième étage, où il y aura une affiche qui date des années 90 avec les différents moyens de contraception.
'fin, je force légèrement le trait, mais—
À peine.
...je ne suis pas si loin de la réalité. Donc, voilà, l'EVRAS a changé, certainement, mais pas de manière très homogène, quoi.
OK. Mais donc, ce qui fait peur, c'est quand tu dis : pas de contrainte sur le comment, sur le fond, sur la forme.
Du coup, est-ce qu'on est sûr qu'aujourd'hui, l'EVRAS est bien dispensé dans les écoles, que les jeunes sont bien informés sur ces questions, ou bien est-ce que c'est une grande inconnue ?
Ah non, on est certain du contraire. En fait, on sait qu'il y a à peu près 10 à 15 % des élèves qui sont touchés. Ça ne fait pas une masse énorme.
Donc 10 à 15 % qui ont des cours tout court.
10 à 15 % des élèves en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles reçoivent de l'EVRAS.
D'accord.
On est loin, loin, loin de la généralisation.
Moi, perso, quand j'étais en sixième primaire, j'étais en néerlandais. J'ai eu un cours en sixième. Et puis, quand je suis passé en français, en secondaire, j'en ai eu un quand j'avais 15 ans.
Et c'était pas terrible. C'était en école catholique.
Mais tu as de la chance.
Voilà.
T'en as quand même eu deux. Moi, personnellement, j'en ai eu quatre—
D'accord.
...des animations EVRAS au cours de mon parcours. Et en fait, quand j'ai commencé mon job ici à la Fédération Pluraliste, j'ai été choquée de découvrir que j'étais une privilégiée.
J'étais littéralement choquée de savoir que moi, j'avais eu quatre cours et qu'en fait, il y a plein de jeunes qui en ont eu zéro.
Parce que, 'fin, les animations EVRAS, c'est rendre accessibles des informations,
à tous et à toutes. Des informations qui devraient en fait être fournies par l'école parce qu'on sait que du côté de la famille, c'est pas forcément le cas.
Et donc, pour moi, les animations EVRAS, elles sont fondamentales. Et ne fût-ce que le fait que les centres de planning viennent se présenter dans toutes les écoles pour savoir que ce lieu existe
et qu'on peut aller vers les centres de planning si on a une question,
eh beh, c'est fondamental et c'est pas encore le cas aujourd'hui.
C'est assez catastrophique ce que vous dites sur le 10, 15 %, mais c'est... Parce que tout à l'heure, vous disiez qu'il y avait un contexte politique favorable qui encourageait ce genre de démarche.
Mais maintenant, vous m'expliquez qu'en fait, c'est désert. 10, 15 %, c'est rien.
Mais le contexte politique favorable, il est très récent, hein. C'est avec la nouvelle législature. En fait, on était ravis de voir que dans les déclarations de politique
régionale et communautaire, l'EVRAS est inscrit, mais ça date de cette législature-là.
C'était pas le cas avant.
OK.
Donc c'est catastrophique. On espère que ça va aller vers du mieux. On pense qu'on peut aller vers du mieux. Après, voilà, c'est quelque chose d'assez récent.
Et ce que j'ai dit aussi tout à l'heure, c'est que je crois que les centres, 'fin
en plus, depuis tout à l'heure, on parle que des centres quand on parle d'EVRAS, mais les centres de planning ne sont pas les seuls acteurs, hein, qui font de l'EVRAS.
Il y en a plein d'autres. Les PMS, les PSE, les organismes de jeunesse, d'autres associations. 'fin, voilà, on n'est pas les seuls sur le terrain.
Le problème, c'est que même si les centres voulaient faire mieux aujourd'hui, ils n'en ont pas la possibilité. C'est ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure, on parlait, en tout cas pour la région wallonne, de l'enveloppe fermée.
Les centres aujourd'hui, même s'ils ont toute la meilleure volonté du monde pour aller dans les écoles pour faire de l'EVRAS, ils n'en ont pas la possibilité humaine et financière.
C'est-à-dire que c'est les écoles qui viennent vers les centres pour demander qu'il y ait des animations EVRAS dans les écoles.
Mais en fait, dès qu'on est au mois de juin, pour l'année scolaire suivante, les calendriers sont déjà bloqués et remplis.
OK, mais donc ces 10, 15 %, d'après ce que tu dis, c'est surtout une question de moyens, une question de finances et pas une question de volonté, pas une question de,
on a un monde scolaire très inerte, très rétrograde, qui n'a pas envie qu'on parle de ça.
C'est une question de moyens, une question d'argent.
C'est principalement une question de moyens. Après, ce qui se passe, quand je parlais des différences qu'il y a entre les établissements en matière d'EVRAS,
c'est sûr qu'en fait aujourd'hui, il y a une grande liberté qui est laissée aux directions d'école.
Et c'est vrai, je crois qu'on peut le dire clairement, qu'il y a des directions qui sont frileuses et qui ne veulent pas. On sait qu'il y a des écoles où on ne peut pas aller parler d'IVG, par exemple.
Mmm-hmm. Et des choses comme parler d'homosexualité, parler de plaisir, des choses comme ça, c'est—
Oui, l'homosexualité, c'est quelque chose qui revient souvent aussi. Après, je ne sais pas si ça vient pour le coup des directions ou si c'est aussi quelque chose qui est tellement
commun à la société qu'évidemment, ça revient aussi dans les discours des jeunes.
Et c'est ça qu'il faut aller aussi mettre en débat, enfin voilà, discuter, amener d'autres points de vue et construire un peu autre chose, quoi.
Ok. Et je reviens sur la notion de plaisir parce que j'ai aussi l'impression que les trucs d'EVRAS, c'est très focalisé contraception, IVG, enceinte, des choses comme ça.
Et très peu sur, ben oui, simplement, la notion de plaisir. Est-ce que c'est juste comme a priori, ou ?
Mais le problème, c'est que quand on a une— c'est de prioriser. Si vous savez que vous avez une seule séance dans une école, il faut aller parler de quoi ?
Oui, OK, ouais, c'est sûr.
C'est compliqué, hein. C'est quoi les priorités ? Est-ce qu'il faut faire de la prévention ? Est-ce qu'il faut aller aborder autre chose ?
Ça, je crois que c'est très difficile et là, j'ai pas la réponse. Après, oui, nous, on parle de plaisir dans nos outils, c'est clair qu'on en parle.
Enfin là, je peux faire une page promo. Page promo. On a fait l'année dernière un outil pédagogique qui s'appelle Anatomia, qu'on a fait avec l'ASBL O'YES, organisme de jeunesse.
Et en fait, c'est des planches anatomiques. Mais on a pris le parti... enfin, on s'est rendu compte que quand on parlait d'anatomie, justement en cours de sciences ou dans certaines animations, en fait, on allait parler de
reproduction, principalement.
Et en fait, qu'on occultait complètement cette partie de plaisir. Donc nous, on a fait un outil qui parle de, c'est quoi le cycle de l'excitation sexuelle du côté des mâles, du côté des femelles ?
C'est quoi un orgasme ? Comment ça se passe ? Et enfin voilà, on a travaillé sur la physiologie du plaisir, en fait.
Ok. Et je reviens là-dessus, hein, mais ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui, ça touche un pourcentage très très faible d'écoles, c'est strictement ou c'est principalement une question d'argent, une question de budget.
Donc si aujourd'hui, vous dites qu'on a un contexte politique qui est davantage favorable à ces questions, est-ce que l'enveloppe, elle va s'ouvrir ?
Est-ce qu'elle va arrêter d'être refermée ? Est-ce qu'on va avoir des campagnes d'EVRAS qui seront davantage financées, qui permettront de toucher plus que 10, 15 % ?
Est-ce qu'on va dans le bon sens ou pas du tout ?
Oui.
Oui ?
Heureusement. On va dans le bon sens. En fait, à Bruxelles, il y a quand même de plus en plus d'argent pour les animations EVRAS, par exemple.
On est passé de 300 000 euros à 700 000 euros, et on espère que ça continue d'augmenter. Il y a maintenant dans les déclarations de politique, il y a inscrit qu'on souhaite la généralisation de l'EVRAS.
Donc nous, on est en,
enfin, on fait partie en tout cas de ce qu'on appelle la plateforme EVRAS
et on a été rencontrer, pour l'instant, tous les ministres pour aller faire du lobby et voir : Ok, vous avez écrit, on va généraliser l'EVRAS, comment est-ce qu'on va le faire ?
On demande une conférence interministérielle EVRAS. Donc voilà, c'est un chemin long, mais cela dit, c'est un chemin clairement où il y a une volonté d'avancer autant du monde associatif que du monde politique. Ça, c'est clair.
Super. Alors, une particularité aussi en Belgique, c'est que l'enseignement est libre, c'est très décentralisé.
Donc ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure, c'est que c'est la démarche de l'école, finalement, de venir chercher auprès des centres de planning familial des personnes pour
dispenser des formations EVRAS.
Animations.
Des animations. Ok, des animations EVRAS, merci. Est-ce qu'on observe, du coup, certaines écoles que ça n'intéresse pas du tout, qui sont plus frileuses que...
Mais en fait, on ne sait pas le jauger, ça. Parce que déjà, il n'y a pas de recueil de données de ce qui est fait, à part à Bruxelles, par les centres de planning, où là, les centres vont indiquer : nous, on a été dans cette école-là
donner une animation EVRAS.
Mais sur le territoire de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, aujourd'hui, il n'y a pas de recueil de données de qui fait quoi en termes d'EVRAS.
Et donc ça, c'est vraiment problématique par rapport au monde. Il y a sans doute des endroits où il y en a et on ne le sait pas.
Et tout comme il y a aussi des endroits où il n'y en a pas et bon, on ne le sait pas, mais on s'en doute. Mais ce qui est compliqué, c'est qu'aujourd'hui, l'EVRAS va être dispensé par des structures qui sont financées par les régions
dans l'enseignement qui est financé par la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Les centres de planning, quand ils vont faire une animation EVRAS, c'est gratuit pour les écoles.
Ok, oui. Donc c'est le budget de la région pour aider les écoles qui dépendent de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Oui. Donc financièrement, il y a un entremêlage comme ça où il faut se mettre, enfin les ministres autour de la table, se dire : Ok, comment est-ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui pour que ce soit généralisé ?
Parce qu'aujourd'hui, si on disait demain, tous les plannings, obligatoirement, vont faire une animation dans chaque classe, c'est impossible.
Les budgets ne suivent pas, en fait. Et donc il faut, voilà, il faut réfléchir à comment est-ce qu'on va agencer tout ça de manière financière.
C'est pas très marrant, mais—
Ok. Oui, mais c'est très bien.
Ça reste nécessaire, quoi.
Oui. Les gens qui vont sur le terrain pour donner ces animations EVRAS, c'est qui ?
Alors dans les centres de planning, ce sont des membres de l'équipe. Et en fait, il existe des formations EVRAS. Donc nous, par exemple, on donne des formations EVRAS.
Pas que nous, il y a d'autres organismes aussi. Mais c'est vrai que c'est pas quelque chose qui est aujourd'hui
implémenté, donc tout le monde doit suivre une formation EVRAS pour aller sur le terrain. Nous, c'est pas quelque chose qu'on soutient non plus.
C'est-à-dire que la formation par les pairs, c'est très pertinent, d'aller faire des animations avec quelqu'un de plus expérimenté et donc d'apprendre de l'expérience.
Mais cela dit, ça serait quand même intéressant de développer plus de formations EVRAS, de développer aussi des formations continuées des professionnels qui vont faire des animations, parce que c'est compliqué, parce qu'en fait,
entendre des propos homophobes, c'est compliqué, parfois, on peut sortir des animations complètement lessivées et perdre un peu le sens.
Et donc voilà, des formations continuées, ça permet de se rassembler entre animateurs et animatrices, d'en parler, de pouvoir dire : « Bah là, on m'a répondu ça, j'ai été complètement interloquée, je ne savais plus répondre.
» Et ça, des exemples, on en a plein, de phrases, voilà, qui mettent vraiment les animateurs et les animatrices à mal.
Et donc nous, on soutient une formation de base et des formations continuées. Mais voilà, petit à petit, ça se met en place également.
C'est comme la généralisation de l'EVRAS, c'est un temps long et ça commence à se mettre en place.
Lola, tu voulais rajouter quelque chose ?
Non, ce que je voulais dire, c'est que, on aborde la question de l'EVRAS par
un petit angle, hein, qui est les animations qui sont données dans les écoles par les centres de planning ou par d'autres acteurs
associatifs principalement.
Mais en fait, c'est beaucoup plus large que ça. 'Fin l'EVRAS, quand on parle de généralisation de l'EVRAS, de quoi on parle en fait ?
Et donc nous, on soutient aussi qu'il faut que
il puisse y avoir une sensibilisation auprès des autres adultes qui entourent les élèves, c'est-à-dire
les parents, bon ça, c'est les plus difficiles à toucher,
mais aussi tout le personnel éducatif, toutes les personnes qui sont en contact avec les élèves, et de manière beaucoup plus répétée que juste une animation ponctuelle.
Donc en fait, on réfléchit aujourd'hui aussi à comment on peut sensibiliser et former les autres professionnels de l'école et en particulier les profs.
On ne dit pas que c'est aux profs,
aux enseignants et aux enseignantes de faire de l'EVRAS,
mais il nous semble très important
que, après une animation EVRAS, dans le cours de la semaine, du mois, de l'année qui suit, les profs puissent être en mesure de répondre à certaines questions qui pourraient être posées par les élèves,
qu'ils puissent prendre le relais en fait de l'animation qui aura été faite par des professionnels.
Oui, on soutient qu'on doit clairement former les enseignants et les enseignantes parce que aux stéréotypes de genre, par exemple, tout simplement.
Aujourd'hui, une animation EVRAS sur les stéréotypes de genre, ce n'est pas suffisant si on a un enseignant ou une enseignante qui va déblatérer des gros stéréotypes pendant toute l'année.
Alors c'est, voilà, c'est comment, comment on dit, une petite pièce dans une fontaine ? Non, c'est l'inverse d'ailleurs.
Mais donc voilà, c'est—
Une petite goutte d'eau dans l'océan.
Oui, c'est une petite goutte d'eau quoi, dans un vase de stéréotypes. 'Fin, c'est compliqué quand même.
On pense que les enseignants et les enseignantes doivent être absolument sensibilisés de façon transversale et qu'ils puissent,
eux-mêmes, déconstruire les stéréotypes de genre qu'ils pourraient disséminer dans leur cours via des poèmes, pardon, des poèmes sexistes.
Moi, j'en ai eu quand mes enfants étaient en maternelle et en primaire, ça m'a, beuh...
Qui ressemblaient à quoi, par exemple ?
Ah, il était super, faudrait que je le retrouve. C'était sur le vent et ça disait : « Le vent qui emporte le chapeau de papa et qui sèche le linge de maman, notre petite ménagère.
» Voilà, là, on était, je pense, en 2016 ou 17. Bon, voilà quoi. Et on nous rapporte tout le temps des trucs comme ça, des gâteaux d'anniversaire genrés, un gâteau pour les garçons, un gâteau pour les filles.
'Fin, sur, 'fin on marche à la tête. C'est plus possible. Aujourd'hui, c'est plus possible d'avoir ça. Et en fait, c'est exactement ce qu'Émilie a dit.
Nos petites animations EVRAS, elles sont super et on va militer pour qu'elles soient plus régulières et qu'elles soient,
qu'elles soient beaucoup plus inscrites dans le parcours des élèves en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Mais c'est une goutte d'eau dans l'océan si, par ailleurs, voilà, on continue à avoir des structures scolaires qui sont genrées dans la prise de décision, dans le contenu des cours, etc., etc.
Donc là, on touche à un problème très belge qui est le fait qu'on a différents niveaux de pouvoir. On a le ministère de l'Éducation qui est la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
On a les éditeurs de livres qui choisissent de mettre un certain contenu dedans ou pas. On a les écoles qui sont relativement autonomes et qui peuvent choisir quel livre ils vont distribuer,
quelle, voilà, quelle philosophie, quelle approche ils vont avoir par rapport aux questions de genre, aux questions de sexisme.
Et toutes ces décisions, et puis en plus, on peut rajouter les centres de planning familial, etc., les formations EVRAS, tous ces différents niveaux de pouvoir, toutes ces différentes décisions qui doivent être prises à des niveaux différents,
qui doivent être concertées, qui doivent travailler ensemble, ça marche pas très bien.
Est-ce que vous êtes optimistes à ce niveau-là en ce qui concerne l'amélioration de, voilà, des constructions, des rôles genrés, etc. ?
Oui.
Oui. Moi, je suis très optimiste.
Mais oui.
Et en plus, ce qui est intéressant de voir, c'est que parfois, ça vient d'une seule personne.
'Fin, je veux dire, dans une école, il peut y avoir un prof, une prof qui est sensible à ces questions-là, qui sait chausser les lunettes de genre et déconstruire déjà les stéréotypes et en fait, qui va faire tache d'huile.
Je trouve qu'on a été assez bonnes dans les métaphores jusqu'ici, mais voilà, c'est super.
C'est un petit compliment, c'est parfait.
Voilà. Oui, oui, je suis pour l'auto-empowerment. Mais non, mais je plaisante pas en fait. 'Fin si, je plaisante, mais pas, pas là, euh...
C'est vrai que c'est des fois par des initiatives individuelles qu'on va pouvoir sensibiliser d'autres personnes dans les équipes de profs, par exemple, dans les équipes scolaires, même entre enfants en fait,
même entre enfants, même dans les jeunes, dans les élèves, quel que soit leur âge, qui, s'il y a—
allez, je vais, pardon hein, je vais donner des exemples perso, mais moi, je suis ravie que ma fille vienne parler des règles à l'école.
Mh. Mh.
Elle en a parlé, elle avait 7 ou 8 ans. Et en fait, le fait qu'elle puisse avoir des informations correctes et les donner à ses copines, ou à ses copains d'ailleurs, peut-être qu'en fait, ça, 'fin, ça fait—
C'est ça.
Je crois, je crois fermement que ça peut faire tache d'huile et que c'est comme ça qu'on change les choses.
Autre chose à rajouter donc sur, voilà, la déconstruction des rôles genrés, sur l'empowerment à l'école ?
Les violences, par exemple, les violences faites aux femmes.
Oui.
Nos nouvelles ministres, elles sont quand même très engagées par rapport à la lutte contre les violences faites aux femmes.
Et donc, ça, en tout cas, les stéréotypes de genre font partie du continuum des violences qui sont faites aux femmes.
Et donc c'est, oui, être optimiste, bien sûr, il faut qu'on soit optimiste. Et je trouve que en fait, oui, y a des choses qui changent avec des hashtag MeToo, avec des prises de conscience individuelles et collectives sur
ce qui est vécu aujourd'hui par les femmes.
Et donc tout ça, et du coup qui permettent aujourd'hui des conférences interministérielles sur les violences, qui permettent des mouvements poli— 'fin, voilà, des nouvelles actions politiques.
On a une ministre qui essaye de mettre en place un décret droit des femmes.
On a une association qui s'appelle Femmes et Loi qui a fait une conférence la semaine passée sur les codes commentés qui s'appelle
le droit des femmes.
Tout ça, ce sont des choses qui vont dans le bon sens. Et en fait, on voit que les luttes, elles sont pas que dans les VRAC.
'Fin, elles sont aussi, on voit dans le monde juridique, on voit que, voilà, ça bouge un peu partout et c'est hyper enthousiasmant.
Je trouve qu'on est dans un contexte qui est à la fois très enthousiasmant parce que y a effectivement de plus en plus de voix qui se lèvent.
'Fin, voilà, sur la question des violences, on l'a vu, ces dernières semaines. 'Fin, on a vu les scandales avec Polanski, etc., les César.
Voilà, y a de plus en plus de luttes aussi qui sont visibilisées et ça, c'est très chouette et j'crois que ça crée beaucoup de solidarité et de sororité et ça, c'est super chouette.
Après, c'est des sujets qui sont difficiles. Donc on a beaucoup d'espoir, mais y a aussi un travail énorme à faire.
Des fois, c'est des individus qui vont pouvoir faire changer les choses, mais y a, effectivement, y a des mouvements collectifs à initier
et je pense que les hommes ont un grand rôle à jouer dans ce qui va se passer les prochaines années et qu'il y a des prises de conscience à faire.
Et voilà, ils ont du boulot, mais c'est chouette. Ça peut être enthousiasmant. Ça peut être enthousiasmant, mais y a du boulot encore.
À bas le patriarcat.
Oui, à bas le patriarcat. Et je pense que les hommes auront à gagner avec la chute du patriarcat.
Oui, clairement. Vous voulez qu'on parle aussi de l'IVG, des avortements, donc, qui, vous me disiez tout à l'heure, y avait un moratoire au niveau fédéral, au niveau de l'INAMI.
Vous voulez rajouter quelque chose à ce sujet-là ?
Oui, oui, on aimerait quand même dire quelque chose sur l'IVG. Donc y a une proposition de loi qui va passer jeudi en Chambre des représentants.
C'est une proposition de loi qui est soutenue par huit partis politiques, et qui en fait allonge le délai de douze à dix-huit semaines.
Alors, y a quand même une grande confusion aujourd'hui dans le grand public. On se dit : « Ouh là, mais dix-huit semaines, c'est quand même beaucoup ».
Non, non, non. Faut pas mélanger le fait d'augmenter le délai avec l'augmentation du nombre d'IVG. Souvent, on se dit : « Y aura...
» En fait, y a un plus long temps dans lequel les femmes sont aptes à faire une interruption volontaire de grossesse et du coup, y en aura plus.
Mais non, y en aura pas plus. C'est simplement qu'aujourd'hui, en Belgique, le délai s'arrête à douze semaines. Et donc les femmes qui dépassent ce délai aujourd'hui se rendent aux Pays-Bas.
Et ce qu'on va permettre, c'est à ces femmes de ne pas devoir aller dans un autre pays pour être prises en charge par rapport à ce désir de ne pas avoir d'enfant.
Et donc y a cette grande confusion entre augmenter le délai, ça va faire qu'il va y avoir plus d'IVG. Mais non, c'est pas le cas.
Oui, j'ai même envie de faire un peu l'avocat du diable et dire : mais même s'y en avait plus, est-ce que ce serait un problème ?
Non, ce serait pas un problème. Ce que je voulais rajouter sur ce que vient de dire Émilie, c'est que c'est pas— 'fin même aujourd'hui, alors qu'on a un délai à douze semaines, les femmes avortent évidemment le plus vite possible.
'Fin les femmes qui ont décidé d'avorter, elles vont pas attendre d'être au bout du délai légal pour aller dans un centre de planning.
Non, en fait, les femmes aujourd'hui, elles avortent en moyenne à sept semaines de grossesse.
Pas à douze, à sept. Donc c'est pas parce que demain, on a un délai légal à dix-huit semaines que tout le monde va se dire : « Ah ok, on est chill, je vais avorter à quinze, seize, dix-sept, dix-huit semaines ».
Non, évidemment que non. C'est prendre les femmes pour des idiotes.
Et du coup, je voulais quand même rajouter quelque chose à ce que tu viens de poser comme question, c'est-à-dire est-ce que ce serait un problème ?
Non, absolument pas. Ce serait pas un problème. C'est juste une prise en charge. Mais c'est une crainte, en tout cas. C'est une crainte,
clairement, dans le grand public, on se dit : « Ouh, augmentation du délai de douze à dix-huit semaines, flûte ».
Et alors, y a aussi une autre chose qu'on entend souvent, c'est : « Mais du coup, il faudrait quand même pas que les femmes se reposent sur l'IVG comme moyen de contraception ».
Ça, c'est quand même aussi spécial parce que, en fait, on se rend compte que dans les femmes qui font un IVG, la moitié était déjà sous moyen de contraception, donc c'est que le moyen de contraception a fait défaut.
Et donc voilà, il a fait défaut. Potentiellement, le temps de s'en rendre compte, on est déjà à onze, douze semaines. Et alors quoi ?
On va aux Pays-Bas. Mais donc c'est pouvoir prendre en charge ces femmes qui font tout comme il faut aussi et qui, du coup, se retrouvent aujourd'hui sanctionnées par ce régime de douze semaines aujourd'hui en Belgique.
C'est important de parler de contraception quand on parle d'IVG, parce qu'en fait, si on renforce effectivement
la connaissance et l'accessibilité des moyens de contraception, logiquement, ça devrait avoir un effet sur le nombre d'IVG.
Y a une étude intéressante de l'OMS, 'fin un chiffre qui est intéressant, qui disait que même si 100 % des femmes étaient sous contraception, en fait, y aurait quand même 5,9 millions d'avortements par an.
C'est un chiffre qui est intéressant. Ça veut dire que même si on avait une contraception qui était homogénéisée sur toute la population, y aurait quand même 5,6 millions de personnes à prendre en charge.
Donc, je sais pas comment on peut transposer ce chiffre à la Belgique, mais en gros, ça veut dire que même si on fait au mieux, y a pas de contraception qui est efficace à 100 %.
Donc, il faut, nous, ce qu'on soutient ici, c'est d'arrêter de prendre ce débat par le prisme moral, mais de rentrer dans un débat de santé publique.
Y a un moment, y a des femmes qui sont dans le besoin, qui ont besoin de pouvoir avoir recours à l'avortement.
Donc il faut qu'on puisse répondre d'une manière la plus safe qui soit et la plus... 'Fin, en fait, il faut qu'on puisse les prendre le mieux possible en charge sur le territoire en Belgique.
En fait, il y a aussi cette croyance que la personne qui fait une IVG, c'est la jeune fille un peu écervelée. Non, non, non, non, non.
La majorité des femmes qui font une IVG aujourd'hui en Belgique, elles ont entre vingt-cinq et trente-cinq ans.
Un cliché qu'on a sur— 'fin, un cliché. Peut-être une réalité, je ne sais pas, sur justement les femmes qui vont chercher une IVG, par exemple, en hôpital.
C'est une grande culpabilisation, un grand jugement de la part des médecins. Est-ce qu'y a une réalité ? Est-ce que c'est facile ?
Est-ce qu'on se fait culpabiliser quand on va chercher une IVG aujourd'hui en Belgique ?
Clairement, c'est différent. L'accueil en centre de planning et en hôpital est totalement différent. On a encore eu un témoignage la semaine passée où un couple s'est rendu à l'hôpital pour une IVG.
L'accueillante de l'hôpital les a remballés à la maison en disant : « Qu'est-ce que vous foutez ici ? Vous n'avez rien à faire aux urgences.
D'ailleurs, vous n'avez rien à faire à l'hôpital. De toute façon, vous avez deux semaines pour prendre une décision. » Voilà, c'était en hôpital.
L'accueil, 'fin, en fait, le fait de faire une IVG, c'est quand même difficile. Et du coup, en centre de planning, y a un accueil, y a une équipe, on est dans un petit cocon, quoi.
Y a vraiment cette idée d'un accueil bienveillant, non jugeant, là où dans un hôpital, on est plus un numéro et c'est quand même, voilà, c'est pas ce qu'on préconise.
Le fait qu'on renvoie une patiente à la maison comme ça, ça dénote quand même, j'ai l'impression,
peut-être un certain rapport à la question, d'un manque d'empathie, d'un manque, d'un jugement par rapport à la décision, non ? 'Fin...
Bah c'est difficile de faire des généralités parce que évidemment, ça va dépendre de qui est la personne à l'accueil de l'hôpital, etc.
Donc on va pas rentrer dans des clichés. Mais je pense que oui, d'une part, déjà, en fait, dans la formation médicale,
donc j'englobe les médecins, mais j'englobe aussi les gens qui peuvent travailler dans un hôpital, y a pas vraiment de sensibilisation à la question de l'IVG.
Donc évidemment, chacun, chacune va être pris avec ses propres convictions, etc.
Ce que je voulais dire aussi, c'est que, dans certains hôpitaux, mais peut-être qu'avec la nouvelle loi qui va passer, ça sera interdit, mais y a encore des clauses de conscience institutionnelle.
C'est-à-dire que dans certains hôpitaux, on ne pratique pas l'IVG. Ce ne sont pas les praticiens qui le décident ou les praticiennes qui le décident.
C'est une clause qui recouvre tout l'hôpital. Donc d'office, si vous vous présentez dans cet hôpital-là sans savoir trop où vous mettez les pieds, probablement que l'accueil va être un peu frais.
Oui, et alors, en fait, en centre de planning, y a beaucoup de travail aussi sur le non-jugement, sur la bienveillance, sur l'accueil bienveillant.
Ça, c'est quand même quelque chose qui est important pour les centres de planning. Donc, voilà, d'arriver avec une demande pareille et de pouvoir accueillir cette demande sans jugement, en fait, c'est très important.
Un dernier point dont on n'a pas encore parlé, c'est la question des violences sexuelles, des violences à domicile entre hommes et femmes, au sein d'une famille, au sein d'un couple.
Comment est-ce que ça se passe concrètement dans les centres de planning familial ? Est-ce que c'est géré par les praticiens, par les personnes de terrain ?
Est-ce que c'est déconstruit au sein des animations EVRAS ? Est-ce que quelqu'un veut en parler ?
Bon c'est une énorme question. Je crois... Alors, pour ce qui est des animations EVRAS, l'idée, c'est évidemment, je pense que c'est une question qui peut surgir de toute façon dans une animation EVRAS.
Ce qu'on n'a peut-être pas dit ici, c'est que quand un animateur, une animatrice va donner une animation, il vient pas forcément avec un thème prédéfini.
L'idée, la philosophie qu'il y a derrière l'EVRAS, c'est aussi de, comment je peux dire ça, de surfer, 'fin, en tout cas de prendre en compte ce qui va surgir du groupe.
Donc les préoccupations d'un groupe, d'une personne, d'un élève, etc., dans le groupe. Donc, on va pas forcément dire : « Allez, aujourd'hui, on va faire deux heures sur les violences sexuelles.
» Non, ça, ça fonctionne pas vraiment comme ça.
Par contre, quand on commence à aborder justement la question des stéréotypes de genre, par exemple, la question du harcèlement, la question du consentement avec différents outils, différentes animations, etc.
Évidemment que ça va donner des clés et que ça va commencer à déconstruire certains rapports violents qui pourraient exister.
Ça, c'est une façon d'aborder la question. Après, pour les personnes qui seraient déjà victimes de violences intrafamiliales, conjugales, etc.
Évidemment que les centres de planning, pardon, sont un lieu où on peut venir parler de ça, où y a des professionnels qui sont formés pour recevoir ben ce genre de vécu, ce genre de, oui, ce genre de violence.
Après, 'fin, y a aussi d'autres structures associatives qui sont spécialisées sur ces questions de violence. Les violences sexuelles et les violences
conjugales, c'est qu'un petit aspect de plein de choses qui peuvent être abordées en centre de planning.
À Bruxelles, on a un centre de planning qui est spécialisé en fait sur les violences sexuelles qui s'appelle le 320 Rue Haute.
Donc c'est d'ailleurs son adresse. Et c'est le CPVS, donc le Centre de Prise en charge des Violences Sexuelles, où donc une victime peut se rendre directement suite à une violence sexuelle et être prise en charge par ce centre de planning-là.
On arrive tout doucement au bout des septante minutes consacrées donc aux centres de planning familial ici en Belgique.
Autre chose à rajouter ou est-ce qu'on a fait le tour ?
Ben voilà, ce qu'on n'a pas dit dans la présentation de la Fédé au début, 'fin, on a parlé un petit peu de l'éducation permanente.
Mais ce que j'ai pas dit, c'est que dans les sept outils qu'on doit produire par an, en fait, y en a un qu'on valorise tous les ans parce qu'il est super chouette, c'est notre Outilthèque et c'est là qu'on est aujourd'hui.
On est donc, ben je décris pour les auditeurs et les auditrices.
Donc l'Outilthèque, c'est un endroit qui ressemble à une bibliothèque qui est située dans nos bureaux, donc au 109 avenue Émile De Béco, qui est accessible à tout le monde, dans la limite de nos heures de bureau.
Et en fait, qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans cette Outilthèque ? Ben en fait, y a tout un ensemble d'outils pédagogiques pour l'éducation à la vie relationnelle, affective et sexuelle.
Donc, on a des jeux de cartes, on a des jeux de plateau, on a des planches anatomiques, comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure. On a aussi pas mal de livres.
On a des valisettes thématiques. Par exemple, on a une valisette sur la contraception où on a mis tous les derniers moyens de contraception pour les personnes qui ont des testicules.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre ? Attends, je regarde un peu. On a des poupées sexuées, on a des... J'ai déjà dit planches anatomiques.
Voilà. 'Fin, on a plein plein de choses et ça, c'est vraiment un endroit qui gagne à être connu et on est disponible pour le faire visiter.
Et on peut tout à fait ici venir emprunter ou consulter sur place ou emprunter. Ça coûte rien du tout et il faut juste nous appeler avant de venir.
Et voilà, on sera disponibles.
C'est ouvert à tout le monde.
C'est gratuit, c'est payant ?
La visite est totalement gratuite et on a un petit forfait de rien du tout pour quand on veut emprunter des outils ou des livres.
Génial. Émilie, un mot pour conclure ?
Oui, venez tous et toutes nous rendre visite dans notre Outilthèque. Et merci Guillaume pour ce podcast.
Mais merci à vous en tout cas alors pour ces, pour ces septante minutes passées ensemble. Et du coup, on se retrouve dans deux semaines pour le prochain épisode. Au revoir.
Au revoir. Salut.
Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour cet épisode avec Émilie Saey et Lola Clavreul. Pendant l'épisode, on a parlé du fameux vote en séance plénière concernant l'IVG.
À l'heure où je publie cet épisode, le texte a été bloqué par les députés du CD&V, cdH, N-VA et Vlaams Belang et il est maintenant renvoyé pour avis au Conseil d'État.
Il faut cinquante voix pour faire ça et ils étaient cinquante-huit. Concrètement, ça signifie juste un délai, un obstacle sur la route de ce texte, mais rien de dramatique, ce n'est que partie remise.
Si vous avez aimé cet épisode, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast pour ne pas manquer les prochains. Et vous pouvez aussi suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tous les liens sont dans la description. On se retrouve dans deux semaines. À très bientôt. Salut !